[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the last week I was
interviewed for an upcoming publication
and one of the questions I was asked was
what do you think is really important
right now that is not getting the
attention that it deserves and my mind
went immediately to the courts and I
hope that this part of the interview
makes it into the article that should be
published later this week I'll make sure
to share it with you when it is because
while impeachment continues to get
attention which it should as Trump's
foibles overseas with our allies
continue to be discussed which they
should the courts are increasingly under
the oversight of Trump appointed judges
and they are going to ruin this country
for decades to come now Donald Trump in
conjunction with the truly sickening
disgusting hyper-partisan Clown Kentucky
senator Mitch McConnell have been
working together to confirm what they
have a goal of being a hundred and
eighty two judges by the end of this
year federal judges who are really
important to our judicial system and
this gets a very little attention these
are lifetime appointments Donald Trump
is on track to put nearly twice as many
of these judges as President Obama had
at this point in his presidency the
Supreme Court picks get a lot of
attention and they should but most cases
don't get to the Supreme Court the
number of cases that in the aggregate
these federal court judges are going to
decide on Dwarfs by orders of magnitude
the number of cases that the Supreme
Court is going to decide on lots of the
judges that are being nominated and
actually confirmed are getting the
rating of straight up not qualified from
the American Bar Association one example
is for 246 year old Lawrence Van Dyke
who was just confirmed by the Mitch
McConnell run Senate every single one of
these appointments is terrible but there
are also tipping points that go beyond
just another judge here or another judge
there and I apologize for punching my
mic
I'm just getting very wound up about
this another example the Ninth Circuit
Court as a whole is historically a
left-leaning Court
there are 29 seats on that court 13 are
currently Republican seats 10 of those
13 Republican seats are trump appointed
even the Ninth Circuit Court is
increasingly trumpian and Republicans
are united in favor of these horrible
and often unqualified judges for example
everyone other than Republican senator
Susan Collins voted to confirm Sarah
Pitt liqu Sarah Pitt liqu is completely
and totally opposed to abortion she
considers the destruction of an embryo a
quote killing she considers that a
killing she has never tried a single
case but she will have a lifetime seat
on a United States District Court in
Missouri
she was also rated not qualified by the
American Bar Association now I could go
on and on with examples but the big
picture is what matters here first of
all this is a reminder once again not
that we needed it if you thought Hillary
would have been just as bad as Trump no
one should listen to you ever again and
the courts were high on the list of why
that was a very very incorrect analysis
at the time and I've continued to make
it since now the worldwide embarrassment
the bogus trade war that's also on the
list but the courts were at the top of
the list from the beginning number two
this is a reminder that Donald Trump's
impact will continue long beyond his
presidency this is something we've been
talking about lately and the courts are
a big part of that as well now I
hesitate to call impeachment a
distraction from this because number one
impeachment is really important even if
it fails impeachment is a congressional
duty when the facts warrant it you
impeach you don't say well it's gonna
distract from this that or the other
thing but number two the judge stuff
would be happening with or without
impeachment and other than
now taking back the Senate we would have
little way to stop what is going on with
judges but there could be more coverage
because if every time one of these
completely and totally unqualified
judges was nominated we had massive
public outcry and coverage on corporate
media it might shame the Trump
administration into nominating at least
marginally more qualified and less crazy
people maybe but the most important
thing about this is getting coverage so
that it puts it in people's minds as
something to think about when you
consider who to vote for in November of
2020 imagine that you were one of those
people who incorrectly thought back in
2016
Trump Hillary whatever it's all the same
if you recognize that one of the areas
where that analysis was so wrong I mean
it was a weaponized argument it was so
wrong and toxic if you recognize that
with judges that argument fell very
short if that is repeated now it would
be in your mind when you think about
2020 and maybe it gets you not to stay
home but to go out and vote for somebody
who will help remove Donald Trump where
your vote will help remove Donald Trump
that is why we have to make sure people
understand the long lasting impact of
this we have to continue to repeat that
this issue of judges every month is
getting worse I think it was two months
ago on the bonus show we said 25% of
judges at some level I don't remember
exactly what it was have now been
selected by Donald Trump Donald Trump's
judgment about who to select when he
doesn't give it to some other
conservative group or special interest
group and actually is picking people
himself it's disastrous
it's absolutely and completely
disastrous so we can't forget about this
I hope it's part of this article that is
coming out about the David Pakman show
in a few days which I will share with
you on social media and I'm going to
renew my effort to continue talking
about this on the show there was another
horrible mass shooting over the weekend
here in the United States of course and
sadly that's not the most notable part
because these shootings have become so
common in this case a Saudi Air Force
officer shot three Americans dead and
wounded eight more people in Pensacola
Florida now Trump came out and made a
statement it wasn't
a strong statement but it can can I
guess communicated the condolences of
the Saudi King and Crown Prince it told
us that the Saudi King and Crown Prince
feel really bad about what happened but
they're good people and they're going to
take care of the families that were
victimized check out this video and
realize that the Saudi royal family owns
Donald Trump spoke with the king of
Saudi Arabia they are devastated in
Saudi Arabia we're finding out what took
place whether it's one person or a
number of people and the King will be
involved in taking care of families and
loved ones he feels very strongly it's
very very devastated by what happened to
what took place likewise the crown
prince they are devastated by what took
place in Pensacola and I think they're
going to help out the families very
greatly
but right now they send their
condolences and as you know I've sent my
condolences it's a very shocking thing
and we'll find that we'll get to the
bottom of it very quickly the king and
Crown Prince will be involved they feel
strongly they are devastated they will
be taking care of people what about the
families who lost loved ones what about
you know all of my friends in Pensacola
and I have a lot of friends there who
were shocked and traumatized by what has
taken place in their community what
about the victims we'll rest assured
multi-billionaire oligarchs in Saudi
Arabia feel really bad that this
happened and they might throw some cash
at the families there is a double
standard that exists on these mass
shootings that has existed for a long
time so we now have a triple standard
let me first tell you the double
standard the double standard has been if
the shooter is American or white
typically the shooters are American
white dudes it's immediately not about
white supremacy even if they have a
manifesto that must have been satirical
or they're falsely claiming that it was
white supremacy themselves the shooters
themselves didn't even realize that it's
not really about white supremacy
it's about video games it's about
parenting it's about SSRI medications or
the Internet
social me it's about anything right
other than the demographic realities of
the person who is the perpetrator if the
shooter is Muslim this is about Islam
we've got to stop Muslim immigration
usually to the wrong countries if you
look at Trump's list from that Muslim
ban it the problem is Islam the problem
is immigrants from the Middle East
except then here's the triple standard
except if they're Saudis in which case
it's definitely not about Islam it's not
about the country of Saudi Arabia the
Saudis definitely aren't the problem
it's it's it's got to be something else
by the way understand what Donald Trump
is implying when he says that the Saudi
Crown Prince and King are going to take
care of the families this is going to be
Saudi blood money which Saudi royalty
will send to American families in order
to get them to quiet down in order to
placate them if Trump is to be believed
he may be lying
Trump lies all the time we don't know
this is what they do in the Middle East
to the families of terrorists when these
says that you understand what what's
going on here your son he went on a very
important mission for us he's a hero
he's a martyr we are going to make sure
you are taking care of every element of
this is sick it's basically another
version of that except in this case
they're talking about compensating the
families of victims rather than the
families of perpetrators which sometimes
die
in suicide attacks the Saudi King and
Prince are the devastated ones can you
imagine now to be clear I was against
that insane policy from Trump of
shutting down Muslim immigration and all
that stuff if you were going to do such
a policy Trump also did it with the
wrong countries he didn't include the
countries on the list that have actually
been sources of individuals who commit
acts of terror none of it made sense but
what happened to the Donald Trump who
when foreigners from the middle-east
commit an act of terror the old Trump
used to say we need to stop them from
coming to the United States they are the
problem Islam is the problem we need a
Muslim ban all of a sudden here it's a
Saudi and Trump comes out and is
actually functioning as the press
Secretary of the Saudi royal family
Democrats need to pound home from now
until the election that Donald Trump
isn't standing up for them the mostly
red state voters in the Florida
Panhandle in this particular case he's
standing up for the Saudis he's
parroting the Saudis just like he did in
the khashoggi fiasco this is
unconscionable but he has to be punished
for it because otherwise nothing will
happen
nothing will happen unless we actually
make sure that this is a story that
remains in the public eye leave me a
reply if you're watching on youtube or
send me a tweet at D Pakman where you
should of course be following me as well
I want to hear what you think about this
about Donald Trump effectively being the
press secretary of the Saudi royal
family after a Saudi national commits a
mass shooting in Pensacola Florida the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let me say a quick thank you
to a couple of new David Pakman show
members starting with David stow burring
and Jade Kristensen thanks to both of
you and I also want to say thanks to a
longtime sustaining member of the day
Bruce Mann has been a member for almost
five full years and as today's longtime
sustaining member of the day please do
support the program sign up at join
pakman.com it's quick it's easy it's
painless and it feels good man I
recommend it so once again we've got one
of these stories where a Democrat says
I've been in touch privately with
Republicans who might turn on Donald
Trump and actually convict him if there
were to be an impeachment trial where
the Senate would vote this is Democratic
senator from Connecticut Chris Murphy he
called it a number of Republicans that
he could count on one hand so presumably
not more than five Republicans who he
says have told him privately they would
consider voting to convict Donald Trump
in an impeachment trial and remove him
from office so let's be responsible
let's evaluate this carefully I must
have gotten a dozen emails about this
over the weekend because remember that
there were claims similar to this that
ended up not coming true between Donald
Trump's election and inauguration at the
time there were assertions made that
there were electors who were going to
defect and deny Donald Trump the
presidency altogether obviously didn't
happen many of us have forgotten about
that already so the question is are
there really five Republican senators
that might consider doing this one
possibility is there's no way to know
because they probably are considering
this so secretly that they've never gone
public about their concerns about Donald
Trump or their their complete and total
sleepers we couldn't possibly know who
they are if that's the case it could be
any of the Republican members of the
Senate what's the point of even
speculating but let's for imagine let
them
for a moment that the most likely
candidates to defect are people who have
shown some public departure from
supporting Donald Trump so that then we
can assemble a list of possibilities and
then the list is pretty obvious at least
at the beginning one is Susan Collins
from Maine on the one hand Susan Collins
has spoken out against Donald Trump in
some cases she's been one of the
Senate's biggest Republican critics of
Donald Trump but remember at the same
time in the end she often sides with
Trump a great example is with the Brett
Kavanaugh nomination where there were
people on the Left saying Susan Collins
is going to prevent this guy from being
confirmed to the Supreme Court and in
the end she went along with it but Susan
Collins is one possibility
another possibility a Republican senator
who might turn on Trump its MIT Romney
Romney has been one of the biggest
public Republican critics of Trump
they've gone back and forth publicly
about their friends they're not friends
they like each other they don't like
each other Romney wouldn't be a shock if
he voted to convict but I also think
that much like would Susan Collins even
if they don't like Trump they end up
being loyal to the Republican Party and
if the party remains loyal to Trump they
ultimately do as well anytime that
there's these conversations about more
reasonable independent thinking
Republicans we hear the name of Alaska
senator Lisa Murkowski that's a
possibility she's been notably not
commenting on the impeachment hearings
so far but it's just speculation at this
point because her name always seems to
end up on these lists and then beyond
that it's really a lot of guessing
there's Cory Gardner from Colorado whose
name is thrown around martha mcsalley in
arizona is a possibility Tom Tillis in
North Carolina maybe David Perdue in
Georgia but it really is just
speculation and in the end these are
political calculations if there is truly
a senator that believes they are better
off politically voting to convict than
not you might see it but we should be
super careful about this because this is
one of those things where even if you
get every Democratic vote in the Senate
which is it's 45 and then you've got
Bernie and angus King who are
independent
tend to caucus with Democrats that gets
you 47 and imagine that you get every
one of the Republicans I just mentioned
right imagine you get all seven Collins
Romney Murkowski Gardner mcsalley Tillis
and Perdue that's 54 you still need 67
to convict on impeachment in the Senate
so in the most optimistic scenario where
every Democrat plus the two independents
plus these seven very speculative
Republicans all vote to convict you're
still short by 13 now the argument would
be if there are seven Republicans
already considering it and we don't know
that there are and all seven were to do
it then it might provide cover for other
Republicans to jump in and then before
you know it you've got an impeachment
conviction with 2/3 of the Senate I
don't see that as happening primarily
because I don't see an impeachment
conviction vote being politically
advantageous to that many Republicans
unless public opinion drastically
changes 62% of Trumpets said no matter
what Trump does no matter what happens
no matter what he says I'm not going to
reconsider my support for Donald Trump
if that's the case you might be able to
find a few Republicans who are in
districts where okay maybe Republicans
there want the Republican senator to
vote to convict on impeachment you're
not going to get to 67 and that's not
going to translate to remove removing
Donald Trump via impeachment I want to
be wrong we can hope Chris Murphy
statement is very interesting but when
you really analyze it I'm not seeing a
path so this is a viable reality I would
love to be wrong and I would love to
hear from you about how I'm wrong or at
least potentially wrong let me know
leave a reply if you're watching on
youtube send me a tweet at D Pakman I
have for you today some of the
absolutely strangest video so far of
Donald Trump's presidency and that is a
really high bar given that almost all
the video we have of Donald Trump has
been extraordinarily strange and bizarre
Donald Trump complained about the
flushing of toilets hmm 10 to 15 times
and about certain light bulbs that he
doesn't like he talked about toilets or
maybe
it sinks and showers quote not getting
any water none of it made any sense it
sort of seemed like it was maybe an
attempt at humor but Trump really has no
sense of humor
some of it seemed like thinly veiled
compliment a complaints rather about
energy efficiency standards that exist
including around lightbulbs it was a
word salad to end all word salads it was
a three-star Michelin rated word salad
from Donald Trump let's take a look at
the video see if we can figure anything
out let's listen to this first one but
together we're defending the American
workers were using common sense we have
a situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and other
elements of bathrooms where you turn the
faucet on in areas where there's
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to see because you
could never handle it and you don't get
any water you turn on the faucet you
don't get any water they take a shower
and water comes dripping how is clipping
out very quietly tripping out people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times as
opposed to once they end up using more
water so EPA is looking at that very
strongly and my suggestion you go into a
new building or new house or new home
and they have standards only you don't
get water you can't you can't wash your
hands practically this so little water
comes out of the faucet and the end
result is you leave the faucet on and
that takes you much longer than wash
your hands you end up using the same
amount of water so we're looking at very
seriously and opening up the standard
and there may be some areas where we'll
go the other route desert areas but for
the most part you have many states where
they have so much water that it comes
down as cold rain we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and
elements of bathrooms they take a shower
and water drips people are flushing
toilets 10 times what is Trump doing
that he's flushing a toilet 10 to 15
times or that it sounds reasonable or
likely to him that's one
question that this raises may be one for
a different day how can any Trump
supporter see this stuff and see
strength or leadership or intelligence
or cunning or cleverness how I need
someone to explain it to me please
here's another clip about the light
bulbs and we're doing other things the
light bulb they get rid of the light
bulb that people got used to the new
bulb is many times more expensive and I
hate to say it it doesn't make you look
as good of course being a vain person
that's very important to me so we'll
have to change those bulbs and at least
a couple of rooms where I am and the
white hand I saw some trumpet comments
comments online where they are just
fully convinced that this is all comedy
like it's all humor beyond just Trump
doesn't want to look orange that's true
but the toilets the showers it's all
humor
according to some online Trump astons if
that's the case what's the joke like
what is the joke about flushing a toilet
ten to fifteen times it's like when
Trump said windmill windfarms cause
cancer and some supporters said oh that
was a joke that was comedy well like
what's the joke what's the punchline I
don't understand how that even qualifies
as a joke this was the line during the
campaign you might recall every
outrageous thing that Donald Trump said
was defended either as listen Trump's
just telling it like it is he's not
being politically correct you won't hear
this from a lot of other politicians but
Trump is just telling it like it is or
the other explanation for equally crazy
comments was he doesn't literally mean
everything he says these are jokes this
is humor you've got to stop taking it
all so seriously because Donald Trump
isn't actually speaking seriously well
well is it which which is it is it that
everything is a joke or that everything
is serious and it's a truth that nobody
else is willing to tell you but in all
seriousness assuming that this does all
relate to building codes if we want to
try to assess what policy
might this actually be related to its
Trump saying he doesn't like all the
building codes and he wants to look at
getting rid of them this is another
attack on sustainability this is yet
another attempt to undo environmental
regulations at every opportunity even
because of this vague ridiculous people
are flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
confusion and that's the policy concern
that underlies this that we shouldn't
forget at every opportunity that there
is an opportunity to either undo an
environmental regulation or just undo
something that Barack Obama did because
that's also another priority it doesn't
apply in all of these cases they are
doing it and the list of things that the
next president will hopefully have to
undo or redo as the as the case may be
more accurate accurately be stated is a
growing list and this stuff matters I
mean I know that you know we've talked
before Elizabeth Warren she was asked
during a recent debate should the
government get to tell you what kind of
light bulbs you use and Elizabeth Warren
astutely said that's the wrong question
a hundred companies are responsible for
seventy something percent of all
emissions in this country the pollution
the question of straw or I think it was
actually not about light bulbs but maybe
it was about straws the issue of straws
is not really the big issue what we have
here are much much bigger issues to
tackle they mostly relate to industry
but if you look at the entire country's
building and construction industry and
you look at these guidelines and
environmental standards they do make a
difference in the aggregate and to laugh
them off or to pretend that the
government wants you to have a crappy
toilet that can't you know that Trump
needs to flush ten times because of
whatever he's doing or whatever the case
may be it's another one of these
distractions and it is yet another way
that the sort of bonus or priority for
dealing with the environmental
destruction is at the individual level
it's the toilet I choose it's the straw
that I choose when there are much bigger
issues and there ridi regulating there
as well I think it's important not to
forget bizarre video again just kooky
video but it does connect to serious
issues related to regulation and the
environment and fine
changed make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show make sure you're also
following me on instagram at david
cameron the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome to the
program today dr. Aaron Carroll who is a
professor of pediatrics at Indiana
University School of Medicine and the
Regan's Strief Institute I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly who writes
about health research and policy at the
New York Times and his blog the
incidental economist and has a youtube
show on these topics called healthcare
triage so great to have you on today
thanks for having me so let's start our
conversation about evaluating different
systems of healthcare and paying for
health care maybe by establishing how we
would measure how well a system
functions what are the key things that
we should be thinking about are they
availability of care quality of care and
outcomes the cost per capita like how do
we even establish the guidelines for
figuring this out so we care about all
of those things so whenever we talk
about a health care system or any kind
of health care reform I always like to
frame it in terms of what some people
refer to as the Iron Triangle but there
are three aspects of a health care
system you always need to think about
how much does it cost
what's its access like how easy is it
how can you get the stuff that you want
or need and then what is the quality
that it produces what makes it an Iron
Triangle is that you can make any one
maybe two of those things better but it
often comes at the expense of the third
I can make a system that's cheaper
tomorrow but then probably it's either
gonna be less quality or there won't be
as much of it I can make a system
Universal tomorrow meaning everybody can
have everything day one again that's
gonna cost more or probably quality Oh
suffer and I can give you the best
system in the world
but then again that's gonna cost money
or
no access is gonna suffer in some way so
the problem is that we are always
looking for a silver bullet that does
all three of those things at the same
time it's just not gonna happen
so most healthcare reform that we want
to consider we have to say what are we
trying to achieve and what are we
willing to give up in order to get there
what are the trade-offs we don't engage
in that
now within those three domains there's
lots of ways to measure a healthcare
system with respect to cost is it public
cost or private cost how much is
out-of-pocket how much of premiums how
much would you still have to pay even
after that how much you come out of
taxes it gets very complicated but the
United States is an incredibly expensive
system no matter how you're breaking
down yeah I want to get to that in a
second I mean one of the things that I
recently read Yui Rinehart's latest book
where when he talked about the cost he
says something which makes sense but I
think is often not in the conversation
that happens at least in the media about
health healthcare which is that as you
point out there is some total cost and
that can go up or down what is the total
cost to treat the average person in a
year and then oftentimes what we're
really debating is actually how should
that total cost be divided from the
population in other words should we tax
richer people more in order to pay or or
so on and so forth is that a part of the
discussion that is maybe not spoken
about in those clear terms sometimes I
think it's part of but it's not even all
of it you know part of it is that we
think we have a very private system and
we do compare it to some countries but
still about two-thirds of healthcare
spending in the United States is what we
would consider not private it's public
meaning that it's it's Medicare its
Medicaid all of which a taxpayer or some
other way you know government-run it's
the VA it's everyone that works for a
public institution but has private
insurance like me I work for Indiana
University it's a state you're all
paying my salary in taxes and you're all
paying my health insurance even though I
have private health insurance it's
public taxpayer money which is paying
for it I'm sure when you add all that up
it's like two-thirds a health care
spending is already publicly financed
and it's
that's almost more per person than any
other country based total and then on
top of that we still feel like we're all
privately paying way too much money for
premiums at our jobs and even on top of
that we feel like we're paying way too
much money out of pocket when it comes
to co-pays and deductibles so no matter
which way you want to measure how we're
spending on what the cost of care is in
the United States it's it's just
unbelievably high especially I mean you
may be the first person to tell you you
know rest is soul but but it's the
prices it's it's not even just how much
are we consuming but it costs more per
unit in the United States than anywhere
else you could possibly imagine
and so our costs are just through the
roof and it's and of course everybody
wants that to be less or lower but you
can't do that without sacrificing access
or quality likely in some way so let's
get into it because it's so much of our
economy right it's drastically reduced
healthcare spending tomorrow we would
instantly be in recession and/or
depression yes so that's another really
interesting thing from Rhinehart's book
where he says if you actually read you
know spending in health care is jobs
yeah in a very practical sense and I
have this idea that if we reduce
spending but get rid of extraneous
things like medical billing and
insurance fraud investigations that it's
all ok some people will have to find new
jobs but there is a very direct link
between total health care spending and
employment oh it's like we're not when
we say waste it's not money that we put
in a pile and burn all of that waste is
another person's income it's it's you
know it's paying for stuff and people
and jobs and not even just you know
drugs but the people that work at the
drug company the people to clean the
offices at the drug company the people
that pave the Lots outside of the drug
it's 16 17 18 percent of GDP in the
United States meaning about what 1/7 1/8
of our economy is healthcare if you say
tomorrow let's instead of spending 18
percent let's spend 16 percent we just
drop GDP by 2 percentage points we
render depression right so along those
lines my you know I I am I believe
Medicare for all
would be a much better system than the
one we have at the same time I have
looked into enough of the specific
proposals that I see what may be a
problem with some of the plans for how
to pay for it and I want to see if you
agree with me or where maybe I'm getting
this wrong it seems to me that most of
these plans assume in order to make the
numbers work a drastic reduction in
healthcare spending per capita in the
United States that would put us
depending on the plan that you look at
in line with maybe Canada or Australia
and I have not seen a good defense of
how that's going to happen aside from
whether it would be good or bad we can
debate that part I understand that if
you eliminate some of the quote waste
from the multi insurance billing system
and different things you'll reduce cost
a little bit but I don't see how it gets
reduced so much is that a fair critique
of some of the plans for how to pay for
it or am i maybe missing something of
some of it yes but I would say it's even
a little more complicated than that
because again I would talk of it in
terms of trade-offs like we were at the
beginning sure so single-payer health
care which is what medicare for all it's
a perfectly viable way to improve access
that's what it would do it would get us
to universe but so that point if they
were what's the trade-off are we gonna
sacrifice quality or are we gonna
sacrifice we're gonna spend more money
and we could absolutely spend more money
and then and everything would be fine
but if we're not then we have to say
well then what will the trinit be if
we're going to significantly reduce
spending at the same time that we're
massively increasing access to imagine
the quality has to suffer in some way
but the broader picture is exactly what
you said like there's no magic to this
single-payer health care systems are not
inherently cheap they're cheap because
they can use their single-payer market
power to force every provider and
purveyor of health care to accept lower
reimbursement and so that's where the
magic comes in Medicare often reimburses
less than private insurance because they
just have all the patients and they can
turn to providers and say we've got all
these patients if you want to make a
living you have to accept the insurance
to where that is theoretically if
everyone was on Medicare then the
government would have enormous power to
say everyone's gonna have to accept less
freedom
that's how it's all going to function
well there are trade-offs to that be it
their innovation be it through what
people are willing or able to provide
the idea that everyone is going to
continue to operate at peak performance
for less money is not realistic and
again we can say oh well we'll just take
it out of fraud and waste that's still
somebody's income that's still somebody
working there's no magic solution so
medicare-for-all is a perfectly viable
way to achieve universal coverage and
theoretically to could use market power
to reduce overall healthcare spending
but there's got to be trade-offs so now
a defender of the Medicare for All
system would hear you talking about that
and say well there's a combination of
things there that would go into this on
the one hand there is a stimulative even
though yes a reduction in total cost is
a reduction in jobs the stimulative
effect for all of the end-users who no
longer are spending as much money out of
pocket if you believe those estimates
and also are not at risk of a bankruptcy
because of unpredictable health care
spending all of that money is going to
have a much more stimulative effect
being spent at businesses for example
that will increase government revenues
and therefore it's all sort of going to
work out in the end and in a way that is
relatively neat and tidy so what do you
think about that I think it's because
Americans have no appetite for cost
control no I think what would happen is
that we if we passed a medicare-for-all
what would happen is the system would
just cost much much much more money
because we could theoretically use this
market power that we have in Medicare
right now to curtail or hold down
Medicare spending and we don't the
government just keeps spending more and
more on Medicare too where you have
politicians I mean Medicare's gonna go
bankrupt it's spending too much and no
one does anything and what when I read
the analyses it seems as though the
access piece may well be as it's
expected to be the quality of care
piece.if managed correctly may well be
it seems that it's just going to cost
more than most of the plans are
accounting for and maybe now maybe
that's okay as the decision that a
country can make and that's that's where
it's like if somebody said to me like
well
which it's like I I believe we have
plenty of appetite to spend a fortune on
health care given that there are better
ways to do this that would provide
higher quality and better access for the
enormous amount of money we seem willing
to spend
I think deep in people's hearts
that's where Medicare for all would wind
up if it was passed is that it would
achieve universal access in order to
avoid real problems in quality we would
just keep spending more and more and
more money because we have no appetite
to say no it would just not hit the
budget projections that people think and
then them how would we pay for that
I think likely if if someone actually
had the political power to get Medicare
for all through it would be on the backs
of things like wealth taxes and trying
to squeeze more money out of the the
people at the very high end yeah I mean
that's part of it there's also this this
would be political reality where there's
never a question of how do we pay for
this war or those weapons there but it's
a debate here and and I think that
that's a reasonable critique yeah and I
think that that's I think that's why if
Medicare for all was to pass that's how
it would work it would be it would just
be very very expensive I don't think we
have much of an appetite for saying no
to individuals for health care stuff
that they have no matter if it works or
not I don't think we have much of an
appetite for for really impending
people's ability to get what they want
in terms of access as quickly as they
want nor are we going to suffer much in
terms of quality decline so we'll just
spend a lot and we've been doing it for
a long time and that's what we would do
and I think the arguments would be if it
were to pass exactly what you said it we
don't seem to worry about how much the
war cost or or how much the tax cut
costs why are you all screaming about
how much the health care cost
everyone's getting it they're feeling
better about it let's just spend a ton
of money now if it were just up to you
because you've looked at so many systems
you've looked at European systems
there's the system in Singapore which
we've talked about before which is very
interesting do you find that there is
some other system that might be better
suited for the United States
specifically so this is what we about
two and a half years ago we did this
thing at the New York Times where we
actually we picked eight country's
healthcare systems and we had a
a tournament like to the bracket and let
both experts and the public vote and in
the end it came down to a battle between
France and Switzerland in Switzerland
one and I think that's a reasonable call
Switzerland has a health care system
which is universal and it is entirely
private there is no Medicare or Medicaid
ish kind of thing it's entirely private
well-regulated mostly nonprofit health
insurance not coupled to jobs from birth
to death from with a sliding scale
subsidy for those at the low end of the
socio-economic spectrum so subsidies
help people buy it they achieve
remarkable outcomes they have pretty
high levels of cost-sharing which we
seem to believe in and their costs are
high compared to most of the world but
not to us and and it's great and it's
it's entirely private there was a plan
not that long ago perhaps a little more
than a decade ago was called widen
Bennett it was Ron Wyden who's a you
know Democrat from Oregon and it was a
Bill Bennett who was a Republican from
Utah so it was a totally bipartisan plan
and they had co-signers from both sides
of the aisle and it was this it was
birth to death exchange like insurance
totally private with subsidies or or tax
credits uncouple it from jobs very
Switzerland like there was a time in the
United States when now would have been
the good compromise solution but in the
heat of the ACA and all the political
ramifications and partisanship it got
crushed then it got run at office no one
will touch that but I personally think
that there's probably more of an
appetite for that kind of tightly
regulated private insurance that could
be marketed as a compromise ish type
solution for America that would still
allow for you know still not government
running it as much as say a
medicare-for-all would be and a
perfectly viable way to achieve
universal act you know heat over some
coverage that's up actually both the
both the French and Swiss systems or
ones ones that we've talked about
extensively interesting interesting to
hear that we've been speaking with dr.
Aaron Carroll who's a professor of
pediatrics at Indiana University School
of Medicine make sure to check out his
YouTube probe
on these topics called healthcare triage
thank you so much for your time I really
appreciate it any time the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Donald Trump did something that actually
takes a little bit of careful planning
he was able to combine slurs against
Native Americans with anti-semitic
tropes and one of the most unusual
combinations of ignorance and
stereotyping and character assassination
that we've seen thus far in the campaign
so Trump went to a group of mostly
Jewish voters and warned them that
Pocahontas aka Elizabeth Warren is going
to take all of their dollars playing on
the trope of the rich Jew who's number
one priority of course is hoarding cash
this was Donald Trump speaking to the
Israel American Council Trump shows up
and starts talking to them like
everybody just loves Trump of course
most are very liberal and don't like
Trump although maybe this crowd was a
little bit different and at the big
picture level Donald Trump seems to
maybe recognize that because he actually
says even though some of you don't like
me you're not gonna vote for Pocahontas
cuz she'll take all your money what you
care about most is money and that's why
even if you don't like me you're going
to vote for me take a look at what
Donald Trump had to say a lot of you are
in the real estate business because I
know you very well
you're brutal killers not nice people at
all but you have to vote for me I've no
choice you're not gonna vote for
Pocahontas I can tell you that you're
not gonna vote for the wealth tax yeah
let's take a hundred percent of you
wealth away no no even if you don't like
me some of you don't some of you I don't
like it all actually and you're gonna be
my biggest supporters because you'll be
out of business in about 15 minutes if
they get it what Trump is saying here is
actually double playing on an
anti-semitic trope Trump is playing on
the idea of the rich Jew but he's also
playing on the idea of the rich Jew who
doesn't like Donald Trump but values
their money over making the right
political choice that's best for the
country so he suggests even if you don't
like me you would vote for me anyway so
that Pocahontas doesn't take your money
without maybe even realizing it Donald
Trump is playing off of multiple
anti-semitic tropes there and then he
adds Pocahontas to it sort of as the
cherry on top this is another bird
of the dual loyalty trope I'll explain
what I mean by that often with American
Jews there is this dual loyalty trope of
how loyalty to Israel may cloud the
loyalty to the United States even for
Jews who have never been to Israel and
are just Americans and there's no reason
to suggest that whatsoever in this case
what you have is the idea of loyalty to
their own wealth clouding or superseding
loyalty to the United States wherein
Trump is saying even if you think I'm
bad you would still vote for me in order
to protect your money from Pocahontas
Elizabeth Warren at another point in
this total gongshow speech Donald Trump
actually said if Jared Kushner can't get
Middle East peace done
nobody can which is of course hilarious
because we knew from day one that Jared
Kushner was maybe one of the last people
that should be involved in negotiating
middle Middle East peace but that's
maybe a topic for a different day this
has been the mo from the start we're
going to do X Y Z it will all be super
easy then X Y Z doesn't happen who knew
it could have been so hard that even the
best person to do it
Jared Kushner wasn't able to get it done
so the slurs of Pocahontas continue I
guess I should mention even though it's
pretty obvious Trump mentioned Warren's
a hundred percent wealth tax plan as
Trump suggests I'm sure most of you know
that that's not true there is no hundred
percent wealth tax plan can you imagine
for a moment the outrage on Fox News if
Barack Obama had said any of these
things you have to vote for me you have
no choice anti-democratic dictator Obama
hinting at declaring Martial Law
but if Jared Kushner can't do it it
can't be done
can you imagine Barack Obama saying
something like if Hillary Clinton as
Secretary of State can't do it it simply
can't be done arrogant pompous Obama
thinks law school professors are the
only people same thing some of you don't
like it at all
but you are going to be my biggest
supporters because you'll be out of
business in 15 minutes if they get it
what 24-hour news cycle for day
if Barack Obama were to have said
something like that it's almost like
Trump is saying out loud what some
anti-semitic advisor told him I imagine
behind the scenes before Trump goes
onstage someone comes up to trump and
they say listen Donald these rich Jews
are gonna love you because they're not
gonna want to be wealth taxed by
Pocahontas okay so just bear that in
mind when you're speaking to them got it
got it most politicians then when they
go out they don't repeat that stuff
verbatim Trump of course is not most
politicians and he repeats it all
verbatim and again just a gong show
strange interview that on lots of
trumpets even the inappropriate nature
of that speech would be completely lost
on them they would again say some of it
was jokes and then most of it is just
Trump not cow toeing to the politically
correct crowd and simply telling it like
it is they are beyond reach but
hopefully folks in our audience
understand what's going on here okay
let's talk about something I've been
getting a lot of questions about over
the last couple of weeks and the gist of
the questions has been hey David why are
you listed on Jordan Peterson's new
website think spot why are you involved
with Jordan Peterson are you part of it
are you not part of it I've not heard
you mention it but they list you so
let's talk about it I haven't been
saying anything publicly because there's
been a lot going on behind the scenes
but I am ready to talk to you today
about it and I can report to you that I
am no longer in any way part of Jordan
Peterson's website think spot but I do
believe I owe you a full explanation
about everything that's gone down and
I'll tell you about it today so months
and months ago in fact it was on July
2nd Jordan Peterson emailed me and said
hey David I'm starting this thing think
spot with some other people we're
bringing in a bunch of high-profile
contributors I thought of you here's an
introduction to the people running it
talk to them and I had no further
contact with Jordan Peterson I was put
in touch with the folks at think spot
all nice people the idea was hey we're
bringing in a bunch of big-name
contributors to our website thanks but
we want you to be on there you can do
whatever you want of course
whatever content you already do or want
to start doing or whatever you can do so
I of course have done a ton of
criticisms and takedowns of Jordan
Peterson and so when I was approached I
thought either he and they have no idea
about that when they invited me or they
have an idea and they don't care either
way it's not my problem so I thought
what is my philosophy on the show about
appearing on different platforms my
philosophy on this show has been when I
am invited to a new platform if it's not
a lot more work for our team because we
are stretched pretty thin I do it and
we've launched on a ton of different
platforms over the last few years we
launched on a platform called steam it
we launched our podcast on Pandora and
Spotify and radio.com we started putting
our clips on D Tube and another one
called library lb ry and three speak and
four lots of these things there are
people involved or founders or
corporations whose politics are not in
line with mine but my view is my content
in more places without requiring a lot
more work for our team is good I can
increase my reach I can get my content
in front of people that's a good thing
that was my thought with the thing spot
partnership now the launch of think spot
got delayed multiple times I think at
first it was going to be early August
then late August then I don't even know
when it launched I think it was maybe in
October but eventually it launched and
when think spot launched it launched
with really no other contributors that I
think were well aligned with the David
Pakman show engagement was very low and
I'll be honest my ability to engage with
the platform is also low because we're
very busy at the end of the day and then
I saw this may actually be an acutely
bad platform for us to be on it's not
like some of these others but some of
these other platforms where there are
tons of contributors and I'm there
putting up my stuff it was like eight
contributors that were being promoted
one of those contributors is Jordan
Peterson's daughter whose content was
being sold for even more than mine when
I which I found sort of jarring and and
in Congress I think her content is
mostly around eating like a meat only
diet or something like that so long
story short I respectfully told them
I don't think this is the right platform
for me the way it's shaken out there's
no real cadre of other contributors that
are kind of doing what we're doing at
the level we're doing it in our space I
don't think it's helping me
they also said we're going to be
transitioning from a subscription model
to more of a micro payments model that
makes it even less suited for us because
we're already on a bunch of those and I
don't want to spread our micro payment
platforms too thin so as far as I've
been told you can no longer subscribe to
me on think spot they are in the process
of removing my content altogether and
this is sort of more in line with what's
going to be our 2020 strategy which is
now I think we are at a point where I'm
not looking to get on more and more and
more platforms and spread ourselves
really thin I'm reeling in the platforms
that we're on we're gonna focus on a few
platforms that are working well for us
so we're gonna try to grow YouTube we're
gonna try to grow Facebook and Instagram
video we're going to grow the podcast
that will be the focus now I got a
couple of questions on Twitter saying
David are you going to return the money
the first answer is we never got any
money I mean we didn't get any money for
signing up and we were getting a cut of
subscriptions for people signed up I
never got any money I don't know what
the payment schedule is supposed to be
there's no money to return but beyond
that I don't know why I would return
money like if people don't like this
platform me keeping money gives them
less money you'd think he would want me
to do that but in any case there is no
money for people got paid subscriptions
and none of the money ever came to me
and I don't predict that it ever will so
that's that and no I also am NOT joining
gave Reubens new platform either I don't
know much about that one but I can
assure you I am not involved and that is
the thought is the story would think
spot we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two David P it's
been a while since we heard from Furious
Trumpets Jimmy from Philly but he did
leave a voicemail and it was about
president Bernie Sanders take a listen
to this David Jimmy from Philly
regarding your comment president Bernie
Sanders yo okay something about that
laughs feels a little too really
maniacal I somehow don't think that
that's a joke but in any case I don't
know what Jimmy is referring to
specifically I did say I am a Bernie
Warren guy but beyond that I think that
there is going to be plenty of time for
laughing after the election there will
be plenty of time for crying after the
election all emotions are going to be on
the table and visible after the election
but for the time being I don't know that
I have much more of a response to Jimmy
from Philly we will talk on the bonus
show today about Hillary Clinton's very
interesting interview with Howard Stern
we will talk about that Art Basel Miami
120 thousand dollar banana thing there
are some interesting things to talk
about if you haven't heard about it I'll
tell you all about it and a new report
found that the United States lost more
tax revenue than any other developed
country in 2018 due to the Donald Trump
tax cuts all of those stories and more
on the bonus show at join pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I'll speak to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]